[Music]
so we're in Santa Ana California in
Orange County California we're meeting
Gustavo Ariana the great food writer as
well as cultural critic we're at
burritos lipoma which is a great low-end
burrito joint and we're doing this
partly to celebrate the legacy of
Jonathan Gould who's one of the classic
Southern California food writers and
what is great about gold is that he
could enjoy food where he found it and
as he found it it's not just what's on
the plate or in the end of wrapper it's
also you know the people who are making
it the the air and the restaurant
everything like that I think we're in
for a real treat here Gustavo thanks for
talking to us all of you we are here for
a summit somber occasion the beloved LA
Times and Southern California food
critic Jonathan Gould has died recently
and he talked about this place burritos
la palma as one of the best five best
burrito joints in southern california
what was his take on this and do you
agree with that I have to agree with it
because this burrito
it's a brute inside is meat called B
Leah that SOB Leah usually in Mexico is
goat stew but this is goat stew prepared
with beef and it's a specialty from the
region of Mexico when my parents are
from Hedda psychotic as a city and
around the central state Osaka thick-ass
and up until wood it's a la paloma open
a couple years ago the only place you
can get this food in Southern California
we're at Union halls and Armenian
churches whenever we'd have our
quinceanera some weddings why Armenian
churches cuz Montebello that's why
that's like the grand next Anaheim in
Montebello is a grand nexus for us and
Montebello had a lot of Armenians so
this was video that sq would only serve
no other restaurant we total up are
gonna start serving it immediately
Jonathan comms finds it so amazing that
he ended up calling it one of his five
best burritos why was Jonathan gold such
a good food critic what was the quality
of his insights for his sense of
adventure ISM what was it about him he
was a Southern California through and
through Jewish kid grew up in
south-central grew up on the west side
went to UCLA go Bruins married a Latina
work for hourly weekly and he was of an
era where he was no longer no longer
there to be hidebound by oh we're gonna
stay on the west side your East LA oh
that's dangerous he didn't care where
the food was and he was gonna go find it
and more importantly hidden subscribed
to this boiling totally world of
high-end food and low-end food for him
food was food if it's good that's what
matters and more importantly there's a
story behind all this food it's not just
what you eat I mean already just talking
about this burrito I gave you stories
about Mexican immigration our meaning
again and again with your parents we get
it you're from Mexico right but but also
talk a little bit about you he started
at LA Weekly so he's you know he ends up
at the LA Times but what does it mean to
come from you know LA if you're a you
know an East Coast establishment person
or you believe that DC and New York and
Boston maybe dominate the world what
does it mean to come from LA and then in
LA what does what does it mean to come
from the LA Weekly as opposed to the LA
Times historically Belly Weekly was the
alternative weekly of Southern
California Jonathan started for them as
a proofreader and actually his first
famous stories were about gangsta rap he
wrote the definitive cover story on NWA
and he had this great scene where eazy-e
is at his mom's house in Compton and
they ask him hey you didn't bring the
ak-47 is like no this is my mom's house
why would I do that
and then busts out like a big bag of
just guns and and Jonathan described a
he looked like a little league baseball
coach handing out of bats and gloves but
to be from the LA Weekly meant that you
were not going to see the world like the
LA times especially the LA Times 1980s
incredibly stiff incredibly boring
incredibly I mean so thorough on all the
superficial stuff they cared too much
about what New York thought about them
LA Weekly historically only cared about
what Angelenos cared about them and
Jonathan came of that and by the time he
went to the LA Times I mean I always
thought his heart and soul really was at
the LA Weekly in those old days and so
when he went to the LA Times for me it's
like well he's bringing a little bit of
LA Weekly to the LA Times heaven knows
that paper needed it your book taco USA
which was excerpted a few years ago and
Rees I wrote a cover
yeah briefly reprise for us because
we're in a moment where we have a
president who who started his successful
campaign
become president by saying Mexico
Mexicans are rapists they're drug
dealers they're disease carriers you
know Mexico's not sending us our best
and some of them are good people yeah
yeah what he says he guessed right I
guess some people you know so we're
there but but Mexican food has taken
over the u.s. it's what maybe Italian
food or pizza was 30 or 40 years ago
before that maybe you know kind of like
German pub fare or something how does it
feel to be a Mexican in Trump's America
even with all the anti Mexican rhetoric
that Trump said what was he eating for
Cinco DeMayo
at his hotel at his desk a taco salad
and everyone trashed him for eating that
taco salad but I said that is proof that
there is hope because if someone like
Trump loves Mexican food then anyone can
and if you first like the food at
mentioning you're gonna have to like the
people people want instantaneous change
and takes time and so in my book talk
what you would say I talk about the
evolution of Mexican food over the past
125 years I talk about how the first
dispatches about Mexican food was that
if you ate it all these chilies they
would kill you they literally would kill
you and now I mean there's more salsa
there's an entire sub channel on a cable
package where all people do is eat goes
back yeah the Carolina Reaper and which
the habanero is the best the cheese that
beans actually the best spicy pepper of
the mall is a small little thing but
what we have now salsa has outsold
ketchup for 20 over 25 years in the
United States there's more tequila sold
in the United States than in Mexico
Americans love Mexican food and
eventually if you have a my theory and
what I talk about in my book if you have
a generation that grows up on Mexican
food loving it eventually they're gonna
be able to see Mexicans as human beings
which is an incredible accomplishment
given that Mexico has been the ultimate
arch enemy of the United States 160
years now or something I can't even
remember how do you feel about cultural
appropriation in this debate and you
know one of the things that's
interesting about your writing in
general and certainly in taco USA is you
know that the the starting assumption is
there is only cultural appropriation is
it going to become more difficult to
play around with food or to do fusion
cuisine
if you know we're in Orange County you
know when and it's already happening but
when Vietnamese start doing vietname
tacos and you know and and Mexicans or
Armenians or whoever start doing
Vietnamese dishes when we're being told
increasingly or it seems to me that's
that's bad form is is cuisine gonna
suffer and if cuisine suffers due race
relations suffer hmm this is a problem
with my son how can I put this there's a
problem with the left when they start
critiquing restaurants and restaurant
tours for cultural appropriation they
don't know the restaurant industry they
do not know how food works they don't
know that the restaurant industry is the
most rapacious capitalistic industry
ever created a mankind this is the type
of place where someone will rip off
their mothers own recipe if that means
they can make a dollar more a month so
of course it's gonna happen even with
this burrito this wasn't being made in
restaurants until would it's a la
problem I started making it four years
ago now all these little launch at us
all these little taco trucks are making
media that ask even if they're not from
Zacatecas
because they know what sells that's just
on the money standpoint and then just on
a creative standpoint who are we to tell
white people I'm sorry to say this you
know white people are fine sometimes but
what are you consider self white I mean
a yeah I'm at yours what I am you're
like whiter than I am certainly I wear
on the spec my grandma had green eyes so
that's a hope yes that part then my dad
was straight indigenous or might for my
grandparents but who are we to tell
anyone you can't cook that food in fact
if you come to Southern California most
of the restaurants the chefs in the back
Mexicans are making sushi Mexicans are
making French food Mexicans are making
jet you know Vietnamese food there's
this great Vietnamese restaurant here in
Little Saigon in Orange County we have
the largest population of Vietnamese in
the world outside of Vietnam but it's
famous not just because it has great
central Vietnamese cuisine which is kind
of rare around here but this is the
place where the lucky no waiters and
cooks they speak better Vietnamese then
the second generation Vietnamese
Americans and they're the ones who are
teaching them about their cuisine so our
Mexicans race it for cooking that food
no our white people erase it for trying
to be rich making off a Mexican food
absolutely not so it's an easy tale for
us to weep and moan on the left like Oh
white people they're just making so much
money off of us Mexicans you know what
Mexicans are lit making a lot more money
off of Mexican food than white folks are
this is why Mexican food has been as
strong as it has been for 125 years
nothing against Italian food I love
Italian food
where's the future in Italian food
besetting you know the last time there
is fusion Italian food was with Marco
Polo introduced noodles and then of
course Columbus brought over the
tomatoes but ever since then or or if
we're not gonna insult the Italians
Germans what was the last innovation in
sauerkraut nothing on the other hand
tacos are evolving again and again and
again this is what food when food
evolves cultures stay strong when foods
and people on the Left they want food to
remain in this amber and but when you
amber I don't even know if that's a word
but if you amber eyes food and culture
that's when they die that's what they
don't understand is that but then what
the I think you're absolutely right and
there becomes this cult of authenticity
anywhere you can never change anything
and it's like yeah you know people like
change what is the the analog on the
right because the right you know and it
is it's you know there's something
darkly and deeply ironic about Donald
Trump hating Mexicans and then eating a
taco taco bowl every day and praising
like I've got the best taco bowl in all
of New York I love the Hispanic
flip of the Left fetish of kind of
authenticity and staying stuck in time
the interesting thing is that the
obvious reason the obvious explanation
is that they hate the ethnic food and
they used to I mean I mean so many
historically one of the worst epithets
you could hurl at a group was how they
ate so Mexicans become [ __ ]
yeah you're a spaghetti been spaghetti
bro a mackerel snapper yeah mackerel
never yeah for the Catholics and all
that because what you're saying by that
is your food's disgusting and since if
you eat that you're not a human you're
subhuman so therefore we could genocide
E or whatever but you don't really see
it I mean I heard someone call someone
the other day somewhere a [ __ ] and
like really that's like from the 1950s
that I get behind the program but I but
also at the same time you do have the
right fetishizing authentic like they'll
start saying oh we want street tacos
just the fetish of authenticity it's
something both conservatives and
liberals hold to the conservatives they
want this authentic experience they want
to see how the other side live because
for them the other side is lower than
them for the left the other side you
have to hit you have to exalt them oh
these poor wretched people we have to
protect them have you ever talked to
those poor wretched
maybe they don't want your protection
maybe they're perfectly fine there was
this case in Portland where these women
were interviewed saying yeah we went
down and like Baja California we were
talking to these women these Mexican
women who are making these burritos and
we bug them we were trying to get the
recipe and they wouldn't give it to us
so we just watched them and then we came
and now we're doing that they basically
got shamed out of business
I would fought them only like don't bug
someone the minute they tell you you
know don't talk to me whatever but let
them sell and to me what bothered me was
this idea that Mexicans aren't victims
always of cultural appropriation from
we're doing it to ourselves and again
maybe these women knew that they were
getting ripped off and they're fine the
best story I always tell them that was
Taco Bell Taco Bell was invented by
Glanville eventually and he got his idea
for selling Mexican food from this Miss
this Mexican restaurant San Bernardino I
was right across the street from his
hamburger and hot dog stand and he
admits this in his biography every night
after closing up he'd go across the
street get some tacos try to decipher
how to make him go back to his kitchen
and cook them eventually the owner of
this Mexican restaurant said look I know
you're trying to rip off my tacos if
you're gonna rip me off at least do it
right come into the kitchen I'll teach
you
so that restaurants named meat la cafe
this year they're celebrating their 80th
anniversary I talked to the
daughter-in-law of the of the founder of
meat like FA Irene went on yo and asked
her was that story true about Glenn Bell
she's like oh yeah we remember him we
would always make fun of this white kid
trying to you know make Mexican food and
I told her well are you sad that Glenn
Bell stole your family's heritage to
make all like a billion dollar rest
friend I'll never forget her response
she's like yeah good for him you know
he's been around for 50 years we've been
around for 75 years and besides our
tacos are better like that's how you
should see these things don't always try
to cast Mexicans or ethnic people as
poor pathetic people they're not you're
pathetic for infantilizing them for lack
of a better term
Jonathan Gould died recently Anthony
Bourdain committed suicide recently is
there something about being a food
critic that is
detrimental to your health um food
critics especially now we're the
truth-tellers we are the people who are
saying it how it is more so than any
other beat in journalism yeah you have
investigative reporters yeah you have
this isn't that but we're telling you
what people are eating we're telling you
what people are feeling we're also
showing I mean in some way we're
anthropologists and that we're talking
about immigrant patterns I've always
said this the first to business is that
an immigrant community always opens in
the United States or wherever they go
they open up a place to worker and they
open up a place to eat and usually after
the worship service people start eating
right there so we're the ones we're
telling you is it a dangerous profession
I hope not I'm a food critic I you know
I don't want to go anywhere yet